hey guys it is Friday which means you
can sit back and relax in the knowledge
that you'll be getting only the best of
this week's gaming news let's get
started first ever need for speed reboot
is on its way according to developer
ghost games the new open-world game is
set to arrive on xbox one ps4 and PC in
the fall after numerous teasers the game
was revealed to be a river of the series
that will feature a fleshed-out story a
day/night cycle and a seamless online
mode ghosts have said that the new game
is inspired by nature speed underground
and they've released a teaser trailer
we're due to hear more from the game at
e3 the warcraft movie is something we're
all hoping won't be crap and is the
first CD renders or anything to go by we
can at least rest easy in the knowledge
that it'll probably look good this week
why is published to the first images of
the CG orc or grim the character has
been designed by Star Wars effects
studio industrial light and magic using
contact are provided by blizzard as well
as photos of after Robert Kazuki there
will be embodying character director
Duncan Jones has referred to warcraft
special effects as quote avatar and The
Lord of the Rings at the same time the
movie is scheduled to release on jun 10
of next year
this weekend deals news I've got
something a little different but just as
cool there you want to give you a really
lovely PlayStation seen to donate into
Nepal earthquake relief you can find a
theme in the playstation store where you
can get it after choosing to donate
increments of money ranging from 2 bucks
to a hundred bucks sony have said all
the money will go to the American Red
Cross and save the children's efforts in
Nepal the theme which you can get for
your ps3 and ps4 is also inspired by
Nepal which is pretty damn cool a long
time ago Rockstar suggested that story
dlc for GTA 5 would be on its way but
this week it seemed that that might not
be the case during it takes to earnings
call CEO Strauss Zelnick was questioned
about whether the story based VLC was so
funny zelich said he didn't recall any
such content being in production
although this was quickly retracted by a
take two representative who said that
Rockstar had spoken about exploring
story mode content it was added that no
further information has been released
and take two will leave it to Rockstar
to share info when they're ready finally
this week the upcoming doom title from
Bethesda would tease with a 10 seconds
trailer which was really only two
seconds but I guess it's better than
nothing the trailer was certainly blink
and you'll miss it which I know because
I did blink and miss it the first time I
sat down to watch it nonetheless the
teaser serves as a tiny gameplay snippet
to kick off the doom hype ahead of the
game's official worldwide gameplay
reveal at the fezzes III showcase on jun
14 let me know down in the comments what
you cared about this week and what video
game you think would make the best movie
and
why let's make on site I tell you about
some old school college developed titles
on the gist Lucy goes over some sweet
witcha tips and games but plays features
project cars that's everything I've got
for you this week games but news will
return on tuesday from our US office and
i'll be seeing you in a couple of weeks
since i'm taking off for a holiday in
New York I catch again soon